THANK YOU SO MUCH, CARLEY.
CARLEY: YOU ARE WELCOME.
AINSLEY: BOMBSHELL DETAILS TO
CASE OF COVID-19.
A HOUSE G.O.P. REPORT REVEALING
THE WUHAN LAB SIGNIFICANT
RENOVATIONS TO AIR SAFETY AND
WASTE TREATMENT SYSTEMS IN
BUILDING LESS THAN 2 YEARS OLD.
MAJOR REMEMBER NOVATIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE, SIGNIFICANT
RENOVATION SO SOON AFTER THE
FACILITY BEGAN OPERATING APPEARS
UNUSUAL.
ALL RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
WELL THESE SYSTEMS WERE
FUNCTIONING IN THE MONTHS PRIOR
TO THE OUTBREAK OF COVID-19.
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. MARC SIEGEL JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING, DR. SIEGEL.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: WHY A MAJOR RENOVATION
AT THE WUHAN LAB?
WHY ARE THESE ASKING FOR BIDS
FROM COMPANIES JUST TWO YEARS
AFTER THEY OPENED?
LOOKS SUSPICIOUS, RIGHT?
THIS IS A BIG, BIG BREAK BECAUSE
IT’S A BIG PIECE OF THIS.
WHY WOULD A LAB THAT’S ONLY 2
YEARS OLD SUDDENLY HAVE ISSUES
WITH WASTE TREATMENT AND AIR
SAFETY?
AIR SAFETY WITH RESPIRATORY
VIRUSES IN THAT LAB AND ALSO HE
REPORTED WHY IS THE WUHAN
MILITARY GAMES A GHOST TOWN?
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE WERE NO
FANS THERE MUCH AS WE HAVE SEEN
HERE IN SEPTEMBER OF 2019,
AINSLEY?
AND PEOPLE WERE REPORTEDLY
GETTING SICK AT THOSE GAMES AND
PEOPLE CAME FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
TO THOSE GAMES.
AND, YOU KNOW, ALSO, WHEN I
TALKED TO ROBERT REDFIELD, HE
SAID THAT SATELLITE PHOTOS IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2019 SHOWED
INCREASED TRAFFIC TO HOSPITALS
AND MEDICAL FACILITIES IN THE
AREA BEFORE LONG, WE’RE GOING
TONED UP CALLING THIS COVID
2018.
AND THERE IS ALSO EVIDENCE OF
ISSUES OF NOT JUST LAB LEAK
BECAUSE THAT’S BECOME A MORE AND
MORE SUSPICIOUS.
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE LAB?
WE’RE TRYING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
COULD THE VIRUSES THERE HAVE
COMBINED GENETICS?
COULD HAVE THEY HAVE BEEN RUN
THROUGH HUMANIZED MICE.
WE ALWAYS THINK OF SCIENCE
FICTION WAS SOMETHING DONE WITH
GENETIC EDITING IT COULD HAVE
BEEN THE WAY THE VIRUS WAS GROWN
IN THE LAB AND LEAKED OUT OF THE
LAB.
ALL OF THIS BEARS FURTHER AND
FURTHER INVESTIGATION WHICH
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS PROMISED US
BUT, OF COURSE, IT’S RIGHT NOW
NOT ACROSS THE AISLE IN TERMS OF
THE INVESTIGATION AINSANCE WE
WERE LED TO BELIEVE THAT THE
FIRST CASES WERE SEEN IN THE
WUHAN AREA NOVEMBER OF 26RBG 19.
YOU ARE SAYING SEPTEMBER BEFORE
THAT, A FEW MONTHS BEFORE.
>> YEAH.
AND NOT ONLY THAT I WANT TO PUT
A SPOTLIGHT ON THE IDEA THAT THE
INITIAL VIRUS AND THE LAB BY THE
WAY TOOK DOWN ALL OF IT VIRUSES,
ALL OF ITS SEQUENCING, TOOK IT
DOWN OFF THE WEB RIGHT AROUND
THE TIME THE SUSPICIOUS STUFF
WAS HAPPENING.
AINSLEY: THAT’S INTERESTING.
>> ALSO IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
STRUCTURE OF THE VIRUS DOESN’T
FIT WITH THE WET MARKET
WHATSOEVER.
THAT’S BEEN RECENTLY FOUND THE
BLOOM LAB HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT CLEARLY CAME
FROM BEFORE NEVER OF 2019.
CLEARLY MONTHS BEFORE.
AND DOESN’T FIT THE WET MARKET
AT ALL.
AINSLEY: I’M SURE ALL OF YOUR
FRIENDS, ESPECIALLY IN YOUR
PROFESSION AND ALL OF YOUR
PATIENTS ARE ASKING YOU ARE WE
GOING TO SHUT DOWN AGAIN?
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE DELTA
VARIANT.
IF YOU LOOK AT AUSTRALIA, THEY
HAVE POLICE HELICOPTERS FLYING
OVER THE BEACHES AND TELLING
PEOPLE TO GET OFF THE BEACH.
WATCH THIS.
>> [INAUDIBLE] THEY ARE
FORCEFULLY LOCKING PEOPLE DOWN.
ARE WE GOING TO SEE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT HERE, DR. SIEGEL?
>> I CERTAINLY HOPE NOT.
FIRST OF ALL, IT DOESN’T WORK.
LOCKDOWNS USED EXTENSIVEFULLY
AUSTRALIA THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AS YOU KNOW AND KEPT
THE NUMBERS DOWN 20,000 CASES IN
VICTORIA.
9,000 CASES IN NEW SOUTH WALES.
NOW THEY ARE STARTING TO SEE
INCREASE IN CASES 475 YESTERDAY.
THEY ARE PANICKING WITH A POLICE
STATE.
LISTEN, AINSLEY, HERE IS THE
SCIENCE OF THIS.
AUSTRALIA LOCKED DOWN THE WHOLE
CONTINENT, OKAY?
AND THEY DIDN’T LET ANYBODY IN
AND THEY KEPT THE ANYBODY’S
REALLY LOW.
NOW, ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES
DOCTORS PRACTICING THERE, THEY
ARE HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
PEOPLE TO TAKE THE VACCINE THEY
THINK IT’S A THEORETICAL THREAT
BUT THE VIRUS, OF COURSE, IS A
REAL THREAT.
THEY’RE RESPONDING THE
GOVERNMENT IS BY MORE AND MORE
SUPER IMPOSED POLICE STATE
LOCKDOWNS.
WHEN THE VIRUS AND WE LEARNED
THIS HERE THE HARD WAY, WHEN THE
VIRUS IS ALREADY GOING THROUGH
HOUSEHOLDS, YOU CAN LOCK DOWN
ALL YOU WANT, IT IS NOT GOING TO
PREVENT SPREAD.
AND THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE LEARNING
IN AUSTRALIA.
ALL THEY ARE DOING IS CAUSING
GREAT COLLATERAL DAMAGE,
PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM AND TRAUMA
AND PEOPLE SEPARATED.
THAT’S JUST THE WRONG WAY TO GO.
AINSLEY: DR. SIEGEL, THANK YOU